c'est très efficace qu il voit il n'y a
pas de trou un dernier test avant de
lancer la production de gilet
pare-balles artisanaux avant la guerre
ni trop vendait de la peinture
industrielle et employer 70 personnes il
a mis son entreprise au service de la
résistance ukrainienne sans manette
pipeau
il y a tellement de gens qui ont rejoint
des unités de volontaires avec des armes
mais sans gilet pare balles sans doute
médicale alors essayons de les équiper
pour qu'ils puissent gagner cette guerre
métro a mis à l'abri sa femme et ses
deux enfants partis à l'étranger
avant de faire de son entreprise une
plateforme logistique au service des
combattants et des déplacés dans ce
hangar les médicaments collectés sont
triés avant d'être distribuée
c'est de l'aide humanitaire pour tous
ceux qui en ont besoin pour kiev pour la
défense territoriale les habitants
l'armée ou les hôpitaux
nous allons dans un endroit j'ai réparé
mais n'en ont pas c'est une école mais
c'est devenu un centre d'accueil tous
les déplacements
anna est l'une des volontaires qui
travaillent ici son mari soldats et
combat au front presque toute son unité
a été tué par les russes la veille
il m'a appelé l'année dernière
et m'a dit qu'ils étaient seulement
quatre à avoir sur lui
je ne veux plus entendre ces sirènes je
veux que les enfants retournent à
l'école
je veux que tout ça s'arrête soc
la plupart des déplacés qui se réfugient
ici viennent dire pin et butch à deux
villes dévastées par la guerre au nord
ouest de kiev
[Musique]
il y avait des tirs tout le temps grâce
à dieu notre voiture n'a pas été touchée
quand on est sorti de la ville mais on
était sous les bombardements pendant
tout le trajet
valentina prépare à manger pour les
nouveaux déplacés qui arrive ce soir son
fils handicapé était aoste au mail
lorsque les russes ont pris la ville et
son aéroport près de kiev elle ne sait
pas s'il est encore vivant
quelqu'un m'a dit que sa voiture était
toujours là bas je m'en remets à dieu je
suis sans nouvelles de lui depuis le 4
mars
la solidarité l entraide sont devenus la
norme dans la capitale assiégée
avec la guerre à leur porte les
habitants n'ont plus d'autre choix pour
survivre
en face à la russie